according to their Bible now if you're a
Christian and you read this verse think
it through first thing I want you to
think about is who do you see praying
like Jesus today putting their forehead
on the ground you will see muslims
praying as your Bible which you haven't
acclaimed to shows that Jesus prayed
that way he fell on his face he put his
face on the ground and he prayed and in
your own Bible if you go in the Old
Testament you'll also find Moses and
Abraham and other peace and blessings be
upon all the prophets praying in that
way I have been to many different
churches and I have seen everything from
singing choirs and Hallelujah and
jumping up and down and speaking in
tongues I have yet to see a Christian
congregation regularly pray in the way
that Jesus prayed I've had some
Christians tell me that there's a
certain sect of Christians that pray
this way I keep hearing that I've heard
that right but I've never seen this and
why is not every sect praying like that
if that's what the Bible says Jesus did
foreign
[Music]